once you're with us his brother and his
family it's not about
we don't care for these things
when I was with you then no one can harm
me
absolutely and uh I've had the odd
little bit of complaining but most
people have been so welcoming and that's
amazing to feel in here like I said the
problems of the West and the problems of
the world how many of them can be fixed
with Islam and even down to basic racism
that all disappears
it's gone this is so many things it's
truly amazing and 15 50 shows
thank you
this is
[Music]
the
notes
brothers and sisters I'm here we're here
with Hassan how are you doing I'm
excited to have you in our town brother
welcome thank you very much for the
welcome we're outside just outside the
dean Center and hoping to get in there
soon inshallah and we wanted to touch
upon something that's trending now this
topic with uh Andrew Tate
I think it's the last religion on the
planet that's the right religion I think
it's the last religion so if it's if
it's the last True Religion on the
planet then it has to be the correct one
[Music]
alhamdulillah you heard the good news
all humanity and use them as a means for
guidance this is uh if I'm not mistaken
probably the most is it correct most
famous individual in the world right
he's the most Googled man in the world
you know is that equal most famous I
would say he's probably the one of the
most famous people Definitely Maybe the
most famous he's definitely the most
Googled so that I would say that means
the most famous for sure someone asked
are you Muslim he said I'm Muslim yeah
I'm Muslim man I'm Muslim man I'm Muslim
yeah yeah and he came out with an
official statement or an official
statement what would you did you see the
word he shared multiple uh Islamic
quotes and I think he made it very clear
that he that he's starting to practice
for the people no you're actually a an
attorney correct and you're somebody
who's doing some wonderful work also at
the same time so when you analyze this
you know what is your what is your take
look I mean growing up as an American
Muslim any time we hear anybody becomes
Muslim I'm Muslim man I'm Muslim man I'm
Muslim man it's cause for Joy you know
we are obligated to have hustle upon a
good opinion of our fellow brothers and
sisters and when they say the Kalima I
remember the Hadith on the prophet
Muhammad was really angry at one of the
sahaba because they were in battle and
one of the sahaba actually cornered one
of the mushrikeen at the time and he put
his sword up to him and the mushrik
before the sahaba killed him in that
battle he said so he essentially became
Muslim said he's just doing it to save
his life and he finished the job and the
prophet son was outraged he said did you
did you tear into his heart did you look
into heart did you see the sincere in
his heart who are you to tell what's in
people's hearts we got to stop judging
others man this is the problem with the
social media culture today everybody's
so busy judging others they forget to
judge their own selves so I think man we
should just have a good opinion of the
brother make Dua that Allah uses him to
guide Humanity that's it and even even
if he was the worst of people look make
daughter that it's a true sincere
transformation Allah isn't for good and
that's reason to celebrate and otherwise
just leave the brother alone and let him
grow in a spiritual journey look in
America alhamdulillah we've given Shadow
to so many people and I cannot remember
a single time we give shahada to a
brother or sister and then the first
thing we do wants to become Muslim is
start you know looking into their past
and asking them to condemn every wrong
thing they've ever done and expecting an
immediate transformation no we support
them privately and we encourage them to
grow and we make Dua that Allah bless
them and guide them how about the
situation you know when the man that one
of the sahaba before he accepted Islam
he's making the pledge and what happened
he took his hand back because he was
concerned about his past evil Deeds that
he did right and some of them I mean
they did some you know notorious CR you
know things burying baby girls alive
right exactly no murder I don't think
he's murdered or buried babies alive
right they literally would bury girls
alive as you mentioned so this man now
he was concerned about that Prophet
Muhammad said hey don't you know that
what you've done in the past you know
Islam race is all exactly his sins
exactly exactly so now I mean it seems
like some Muslims understand that there
was uh something that's out there I
wanted to share with you
and you made something as they you
shared some with me it had me thinking
about it you said if Hollywood lead or
um you know if if they were living today
they would if they accepted Islam how do
you think the reaction would be from
some of these uh it's all these people
will be protesting right I mean we would
protest because of the bad that they had
done before Islam and then you remember
the Hadith that Omar even when he was
bowing down the idols Allah still loved
them because he knew his final end you
know what I'm saying so the fact is
Islam has transformed some of the worst
people amongst humanity and made them
into great people we don't know what's
going to happen for this brother but we
hope it does and we should make Dua that
it doesn't we should celebrate that it's
nothing that we should be so quick to
condemn and we gotta be realistic with
our expectations we got people getting
advice oh he shouldn't speak out now or
he should you know condemn a b and c
that he's done before brother and
sisters do we do that for any other
convert let's be realistic you know it's
not easy these days to declare the
shahada publicly I don't think it's
something that people do for fame
there's a huge attack against Islam and
Muslims in the world today and if the
most popular young man publicly is
declaring yes that will be a means to
influence others and it will be a means
you know and look the average American
Muslim guy or young person that follows
it may not be familiar with every good
and bad thing he's done I don't think
that matters with what matters is
they're seeing somebody publicly saying
they believe that there's only one God
Muhammad is his messenger and inshallah
through that we see a positive
transformation but let's just have the
same expectations we do for him that we
do for anyone that converts let's be
realistic you know transforming and
taking the Shad that's a lifelong
process and we should support not
condemn and young young brothers and
sisters and people need to know I mean
obviously he's he's not our role model
is Prophet Muhammad peace
and whatnot now he inshallah the more he
learns Islam he starts living it he's
going to be mimicking hopefully God
willing Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessed be upon him and you're going to
see all of these things of the past
hopefully they're going to get rectified
it will have reform will happen but it
won't happen if people are too busy
condemning and demanding yeah it'll
happen when people privately and
sincerely engage with them as a brother
and try to nourish that spiritual growth
otherwise we really push people away
from Islam and we don't want to do that
okay so this is I guess something that
was going around this was by a sister
actually and it says if Andrew this is
very surprising so
what would you say to this if Andrew
Tate tries to become Muslim or parades
himself around as a Muslim and gets
accepted I'm leaving Islam
abandon Islam in this Dunya altogether
Muslims are honestly the most mentally
ill-subservient idiots on Earth Allah
asks why I'll tell him
first of all anybody who says that is
likely left Islam a while ago wow we ask
Allah to guide her you know the
prophetam said whoever said the people
are doomed and destroyed is the most
doomed and destroyed of them why this
toxic and negative mentality towards our
faith and our community and and I doubt
that person would say the same thing if
if somebody who supports lgbtq rights
and feminism becomes Muslim you know
they would celebrate that but it's
because they don't align with some of
this person's past views that's why
they're so angry and enraged and again
would they have said the same about
Malcolm X I mean Malcolm X said hopes a
plane filled with white people all
crashes and dies
you know and his transformation didn't
come immediately even after initially
become becoming Muslim he still had some
very problematic and actually racist
views to the opposite because of the
racism he had faced his whole life so it
took years for him to reach the beauty
of what Islam is about and likewise you
know it may take a while for the brother
to grow and we should support that and
welcome that and we should be too busy
judging ourselves but anybody who says
anything sick like that it's likely
they've already left us up how can you
speak about our faith in our community
with such disdain and such hate and how
can we not recognize the real challenges
Humanity faces I mean there is so much
right now pulling people away into
secularism and Atheism and if a person
finds guidance and takes steps for it we
should welcome it and listen he's like
you said he's not a role model we don't
think he's the savior of the Muslim
Community or Humanity but we should wish
good for him and hope Allah uses him for
good and surely if Allah uses his skill
sets to speak confidently he uses his
platform his popularity as a means of
Tao then that's good you know
we know some poets became Muslim and
then they used their poetry to call
people to Allah
the prophet taught us that Allah will
use the strengths of people in in Aid of
this religion even said Allah will use
even Wicked people to strengthen Islam
so who are we to cancel anyone or
excommunicate anyone I think we all got
to take a step back mind our own
business worry about ourselves and let
the brother grow in a spiritual journey
and pray to Allah that Allah uses him
for goodness I mean I mean he already
started doing dawah I mean if you don't
look at his quote he's telling
Christians out there when he said this
is why I'm Muslim and then he shows a
video out there I saw the video with the
alphabet stuff that's going on and that
and then he says he quotes an Ayah from
the Quran
so this is amazing and this he's saying
this is why all Christians should be
Muslims ones who have submitted their
will to the creator of the heavens and
earth can I be real to you brother I
think Allah is using him and has used
him already as an antidote to the
extreme inferiority complex a lot of
Muslims have you know there's too many
Muslims right now that are just afraid
to even identify as Muslim Who hide
their name Who hide their identity and
Allah is showing them listen if I'm
showing you people who are proud to
announce their faith to humanity
regardless of their shortcomings they're
proud to declare that they follow
Muhammad what excuse do we have so I
really think Allah is using to push
people to hey be more assertive in your
faith again on the day of judgment Allah
is not going to ask you about him he's
going to ask you about yourself so what
are we doing to grow and I gotta bear
with you also brother especially Living
in America man it breaks my heart when I
see some people
they're prouder of their you know uh
deviant lifestyle they're proud of their
sins they're if they're a man they feel
like they're a woman they're not ashamed
to dance in a parade as a woman even
though they're a man and they're more
proud of their deviant identity than
some Muslims are part of their faith and
their identity and I think we need a
wake-up call and I think Andrew Tate
become Muslim is maybe a wake-up call
for us that's that's uh that's huge most
famous man like you said most Googled
man most famous man if you want to call
it who has used what God Almighty Allah
gave him he's following his fitra along
a throwing up uh Trinity throwing up
pure monotheism and the more he learns
Islam obviously that's going to make him
a better human being
the gambling the debauchery all those
other things in time boom yeah people
are already evaluating his prayer he
just started the guy just started like
leave it just don't expect from him
anything different than you'd expect of
another convert that so many people
become Muslim they're not wearing hijab
on day one maybe they're still
struggling with zinna with alcohol I'm
not gonna sit there and condemn them I'm
gonna tell them that's Haram and I'm
going to support you to leave it but I'm
not going to set unrealistic
expectations don't listen yeah don't say
unrealistic expectations people are
people let's nourish them and let's just
wish good the problem I got remember the
prophet saws is wishing well for others
a lot of people they don't wish well
they want to see him fail they want to
prove a point you know no wish good and
Allah is capable of over all things send
him messages of love and support right
now absolutely absolutely you know just
finishing off so we are where are we
right now this is Route 60.
in a very busy road in the vicinity of
Tampa not far from Orlando just a
tremendous opportunity right now for us
to engage in dawa for our fellow
Floridians and Americans and this is the
future sure so we're filming the D show
outside the DC we should be inside the
dean Center so you you got to help us to
get the D show inside the dean Center
and that's what we're outside now we
want to be inside so inshallah you can
help us and support us here uh we're in
your backyard alhamdulillah welcome
we're so excited to have you and we pray
that this Center becomes a source of
guidance not just for the people of
Florida or even America but for all
Humanity becomes that millions and
millions find guidance through the
sincere efforts that you are
establishing right now with the sincere
support of everyone who donates to
support this beautiful initiative have
you welcomed my brother to see more
often inshallah exactly
we've been told that uh they're out to
kill us all assalamualaikum brothers and
sisters we went to the streets to ask
Americans about Islam here's what they
said do you know anything about Islam No
do you know anything about Islam No
sadly do you know anything about Islam
uh not really do you know anything about
Islam
no sorry you know what Islam means Islam
uh no we've been told that uh they're
out to kill us all that's what you've
been told that Muslims are out to kill
you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you're gonna have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click the Donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedineshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum